bienvenue en terre celte vu du ciel on
constate l'importance de cette sépulture
avec ses 40 mètres de diamètre
depuis un mois maintenant les
archéologues sont à pied d'oeuvre
l'objectif en savoir plus sur ce
monument funéraire
ce sont les seuls fouilles menées depuis
la découverte du site et de son fabuleux
trésor c'était en 1953 il ya évidemment
l'espoir de retrouver de petits éléments
qui auraient été oubliés qui peuvent
être extrêmement important évidemment on
sait qu'il ya des erreurs qui font
quelques centimètres des perles des
choses comme ça qui ont pu être oubliés
mais je pense que par exemple trouver un
pieux en bois important c'est qu'on
pourrait pas compter une datation très
précise à l'ats tombes princières de vix
et son fameux vase c'est un peu pour
nous français notre trésor de
toutankhamon une histoire extraordinaire
commencé en 1953 avec la découverte de
la sépulture d'une princesse cents
datant du 6e siècle avant jésus-christ
soixante-six ans après la dame de vix
fait toujours sensation
pour preuve la présence massive de la
presse à la réouverture des fouilles des
fouilles et soutenu par la drac mené par
l'inrap et le laboratoire artehis est
voulue par la communauté de communes
fussent porter acquéreur du terrain
1 une manière à pouvoir fouiller
librement ainsi je puis dire et ça qui
est aussi un budget conséquent
c'est lors de quatre à cinq cent mille
euros donc avec différents partenaires
on a réussi à trouver des accords pour
faire en sorte que presque 110 ans après
on puisse enfin rouvrir ce tumulus
ces fouilles vont se poursuivre jusqu'à
mi novembre elles lèveront peut-être le
voile sur les derniers mystères du
tombeau de la dame de vix
[Musique]